[Music]
[Applause]
two a.m. on November 9th 2016 I was
alone in the middle of the street
shouting at the top of my lungs Donald
Trump had just been announced as the
next president of United States I was
overcome by emotion and the shouting was
helping it was helping release some of
that emotional pressure I had been
feeling you know what people a lot of
people felt a lot of things that day
some people were ecstatic
finally a president had been elected
that really understood their needs and
others were really sad how could someone
who had been so divisive once for me
those feelings that night those shouts
were all about anger I was angry because
of the uncertainty I knew a trump
presidency would bring from my own
country Mexico I've thought a lot about
that night what I did but I could have
done and you know what I would have done
if I could go back I would have gone
into a library and I would have brought
some regressions today I'd like to tell
you why with the hope that maybe by
telling you the way I dealt with those
emotions it can help you figure out how
to deal with the emotions you might be
saying I was born and raised in Mexico I
grew up in a family that has always
believed that the Mexico the Mexican the
US should be closer together my dad was
the chief architect and negotiator for
Mexico the North American Free Trade
Agreement I came to study college in the
u.s. I worked here after that I am about
to graduate from two masters degrees
here in the US I came to study and work
in the United States because I hope to
live a life that allows me to bring the
two countries closer together
I love Mexico and I have a profound
admiration for the United States for me
it's always been obvious that bringing
our two countries closer together it's a
good thing and yet Donald Trump seems to
stand for completely the opposite of
that I was so angry that night because I
couldn't help but feel that he had won
precisely because he had promised to
divide our two countries
he's literally promised to build a wall
between our two countries and that made
me angry I was desperate to take action
to do something but I didn't know what
to do so instead I started expressing my
emotions in all kinds of platforms
whatsapp Facebook emails in front of
people anything that I could do to share
how I was feeling I shared how I was
angry how I hated that the US was doing
this to us I even said I hated the US
and to be honest all of Mexico started
doing the same and suddenly the
discourse in Mexico towards the United
States changed in a way that it hadn't
changed in over three decades anti-us
feelings became the norm an extreme
left-wing presidential candidate who is
incredibly anti us is now the
frontrunner for the presidential
elections in our country people started
calling for US companies to be kicked
out of Mexico for tariffs to be imposed
on us imports people started calling for
mexico to push the u.s. out
when I saw that all that anger I had
been feeling became work suddenly
despite everything I had been feeling
and saying I realized that pushing the
u.s. out was not the right course of
action no what we needed was finding
ways to keep letting the u.s. in and so
I set out to prove that with data I
suddenly had something to do wasn't the
most exciting action but it was some
action it consisted in locking myself up
in a library looking at data sets and
running regressions you know we can
think of what NAFTA did and two big
things one was that it lowered US
tariffs
for Mexican products those are the
tariffs that Donald Trump has threatened
to raise the second thing it did is that
it lowered Mexican tariffs for u.s.
products now Donald Trump gets to decide
what he wants to do with his tariffs but
we as Mexico we get to decide what we
want to do with ours and so the question
for me was what should we do with our
tax should we raise them and push the
u.s. out or should we keep them at zero
and keep letting the US come in the
answer wasn't obvious spent a lot of
days in the library but suddenly I
figured out I was able to show that
Mexico has grown much more because
Mexico lowered its tires from the US
products then because the u.s. lowered
its hours on us that means that free
trade has been good for Mexico that
means that businesses in our country
have grown because we opened up to the
u.s. that means that we shouldn't push
the u.s. out but rather keep finding
ways to let them in
running those regressions gave me
clarity I suddenly knew what I had to do
I had to find ways for Mexico in the
u.s. to keep even close to one another
even if my feelings were telling me not
to do that we are all feeling a lot of
things these days these are emotional
times some of us are facing the most
challenging issues many of us have ever
seen and it's hard to overcome the
emotions we're feelings sometimes they
can paralyze us and other times they can
jump it into action that we maybe
haven't fully thought out so today I
want to ask you to compliment those
emotions and those feelings with data
and analysis if you're feeling paralyzed
jump into the data of whatever it is you
care about I may be that analysis will
give you clarity on how to move forward
and if you're already jumping into
action then maybe pause for a moment and
make sure by looking at the data that
what you're doing is going to help if
you're marching and protesting keep
marching and protesting but make sure
you have the data to back that up when I
start preparing to give this talk a
couple months ago my intent was to argue
that the way we can counter the
inflammatory and outrageous statements
made by someone like Donald Trump by
being equally outrageous and
inflammatory ourselves and while that
might feel good for an instant it's not
going to do anything No
today more than ever we need to focus on
facts on data on analysis so the next
time that you're feeling like you want
to go run some regressions thank you
[Applause]
[Music]